J'aimerais commencer par une merveilleuse citation d'Einstein,
afin que les gens réalisent que ce grand scientifique du 20ème siècle
partage aussi notre avis, et nous appelle à agir.
Il a dit, "L'être humain est un élément de cet ensemble que l'on appelle univers,
un élément limité dans le temps et dans l'espace.
Il fait l'expérience de lui-même, de ses pensées et de ses sentiments,
comme quelque chose de détaché du reste,
et ce détachement est une sorte d'illusion d'optique de sa conscience.
Cette illusion est notre propre prison,
qui nous limite à nos désirs personnels et à de l'affection pour nos proches.
Nous devons nous libérer de cette prison en élargissant la sphère de notre compassion,
et englober toutes les créatures vivantes et la nature dans toute sa splendeur".
Cette pensée d'Einstein est étrangement proche de la philosophie bouddhiste
dans laquelle la compassion, appelée karuna,
est définie comme "la sensibilité à la souffrance de l'autre
et la volonté de le libérer de cette souffrance".
Cela va de pair avec l'amour, qui est vouloir le bonheur de l'autre.
Cela demande, bien sûr, que l'on ressente le bonheur soi-même
et qu'on veuille le partager.
La comparaison est juste en cela qu'elle oppose clairement l'égocentrisme
et l'égoïsme à la compassion, le souci des autres,
et cela montre aussi que ceux qui sont pris dans l'engrenage de l'égocentrisme,
souffrent désespérément, tandis que celui qui éprouve de la compassion est plus libre
et implicitement plus heureux.
Le Dalai Lama explique souvent que la compassion est sa meilleure amie.
Elle l'aide lorsqu'il est abattu par le chagrin et le désespoir.
La compassion l'aide à s'éloigner de son sentiment de souffrance
la souffrance la plus absolue, la plus terrible qu'on puisse ressentir
et élargit son attention à la souffrance des autres,
même à celle de ses tourmenteurs et de tous les êtres du monde.
En fait, la souffrance est si énorme et profonde
que sa propre souffrance devient de moins en moins monumentale.
Et il commence à passer au-delà du souci de soi-même pour l'élargir à celui des autres.
Cela le rend tout de suite joyeux,
et son courage est stimulé pour être à la hauteur de la situation.
Ainsi, il utilise sa propre souffrance
comme un passage vers l'élargissement de la sphère de sa compassion.
Il est un très bon collègue d'Einstein, il faut le reconnaître.
Je vais vous raconter une histoire,
très célèbre dans la tradition indienne et bouddhiste,
celle du célèbre saint homme Asanga
un contemporain de St Augustin en Occident,
et qui était un peu comme un Saint Augustin boudhiste.
Asanga vivait 800 ans après l'époque de Bouddha.
Il n'était pas satisfait de la façon dont les gens pratiquaient
la religion bouddhiste en Inde à cette époque.
Il a dit un jour : "J'en ai assez. Cette doctrine, personne ne la vit réellement.
Ils parlent d'amour, de compassion, de sagesse et de révélation,
mais ils se comportent comme des égoïstes, ils sont lamentables.
L'enseignement de Bouddha a perdu de son impulsion.
Je sais que le prochain Bouddha viendra dans des milliers d'années,
mais il existe aujourd'hui dans un paradis, il s'appelle Maitreya.
Je vais donc me retirer, et je vais méditer
et prier jusqu'à ce que Bouddha Maitreya se révèle à moi,
et me donne un enseignement ou quelque chose
pour raviver la pratique de la compassion dans le monde d'aujourd'hui".
Alors il se retira du monde. Et il médita pendant trois ans
sans voir le futur Bouddha Maitreya.
Et il s'en fut, écoeuré.
Alors qu'il partait, il vit
un drôle de petit bonhomme assis au milieu de la montagne.
Et il tenait un morceau de fer.
Il le frottait avec un bout de tissu.
Et cela commença à l'intriguer.
Il lui demanda : "Qu'est-ce que tu fais ?"
L'homme répondit : "Je fabrique une aiguille".
Il répondit : "C'est ridicule. Tu ne peux pas fabriquer une aiguille
en frottant un morceau de fer avec un bout de tissu".
et l'homme répondit : "Vraiment ?" Et il lui montra un plat rempli d'aiguilles.
Alors il dit : "C'est bon, j'ai compris".
Il retourna dans sa cave. Il recommença à méditer.
Trois années passent, et pas de visions. A nouveau, il s'en va.
Cette fois, il arrive au pied de la montagne.
Alors qu'il partait, il voit un oiseau faire son nid sur la corniche d'une falaise.
Et à l'endroit où il se pose pour apporter les brindilles sur la corniche,
ses plumes frottent la roche, et avaient fini par y faire une entaille.
A vingt centimètres de profondeur, il y avait une fissure dans la roche
causée par le frottement des plumes des oiseaux pendant des générations.
Alors il dit : "C'est bon, j'ai compris". Il repartit.
Trois années passent.
Et toujours aucune vision de Maitreya après neuf années.
A nouveau il s'en va, et cette fois il voit de l'eau
couler au goutte-à-goutte, creusant une cuvette géante dans la roche.
Alors il repart. Et après douze années, il n'a toujours aucune vision.
Il prend peur. Il regarde droit devant lui
pour éviter toute distraction.
Il arrive à la ville. C'est un homme brisé.
Et là, dans ce village, un chien s'approche de lui,
un de ces chiens répugnants qu'on trouve dans les pays pauvres,
même en Amérique, dans certains endroits -
et il est tout simplement répugnant.
Il est intrigué par ce chien misérable,
qui essaye d'attirer son attention. Il s'assoit et observe le chien.
L'arrière-train de l'animal n'est qu'une plaie ouverte.
Une plaie horrible, attaquée par la gangraine.
Des vers grouillent dans la chair. C'est affreux.
Il réfléchit : "Que puis-je faire pour soigner ce chien ?
Au moins, je pourrais nettoyer sa plaie."
Il l'emmène avec lui chercher de l'eau pour le nettoyer,
lorsque les vers attirent son attention.
Il regarde les vers, et il trouve qu'après tout ils sont plutôt mignons.
Et ils étaient là, à cheniller joyeusement dans l'arrière-train du chien.
"Bon, si je nettoie le chien, je tuerai les vers. Comment faire ?
C'est tout. Je suis inutile et Bouddha n'existe pas, ni Maitreya,
et il n'y a pas d'espoir.
Et maintenant je vais tuer ces vers ?"
Il eut alors une idée géniale.
Il ramassa un débris qui traînait et découpa un morceau de chair dans sa cuisse,
qu'il posa ensuite par terre.
Il avait autre chose en tête que penser à la SPA.
Il était pris dans le feu de l'action.
Il réfléchit : "Je vais enlever ces vers et les poser sur ce bout de chair,
ensuite je vais nettoyer les blessures du chien,
et ensuite je trouverai bien quoi faire des vers."
Il se met au travail. Il n'arrive pas à attraper les vers
qui se tortillent dans tous les sens. Pas facile à attraper, ces asticots.
Alors il se dit : "Je vais poser ma langue sur la chair du chien.
Les vers pourront sauter sur ma langue, plus vivante.
Il n'y a plus rien à manger sur le chien.
Ensuite je les cracherai un par un sur le bout de chair."
Alors il se baisse, et tire la langue, comme ça.
Il devait fermer les yeux à cause de l'odeur dégoûtante et tout le reste.
Soudain, il entend un "pffft", un bruit dans ce genre-là.
Il recule d'un bond et là, bien entendu, il voit le futur Bouddha Maitreya.
C'est une vision magnifique, comme un arc-en-ciel, un corps doré, vaporeux, orné de pierres précieuses,
c'est comme une vision mythique exquise.
Et il s'exclame : "Oh." Il s'incline.
Mais, comme tous les être humains, la première chose qu'il fit fut de se plaindre.
Alors qu'il se redresse, il dit :
Mon Dieu, je suis si heureux de vous voir, mais où étiez-vous pendant 12 ans ?
Qu'est-ce ça veut dire ?"
Maitreya répondit : "J'étais avec toi. A ton avis, qui fabriquait des aiguilles,
qui faisait des nids, qui faisait tomber les gouttes d'eau, gros bêta ?"
(Rires)
"Tu cherchais Bouddha en personne", dit-il.
Et il dit :"Jusqu'à présent, tu n'as jamais éprouvé de réelle compassion.
Et, tant que tu n'éprouves pas cette compassion, tu ne peux pas reconnaître l'amour".
Maitreya parle d'amour, l'amour affectueux, en Sanskrit.
Et là, Asanga eut l'air dubitatif.
Alors Maitreya dit : " Si tu ne me crois pas, emmène-moi avec toi."
Et il emmena Maitreya - qui se rétrécit jusqu'à tenir dans un globe -
il le prit sur son épaule.
Et il courut au centre de la ville et cria: "Réjouissez-vous ! Réjouissez-vous !
Le futur Bouddha est arrivé plus tôt qu'on ne le prédisait. Le voici."
Et très vite les gens commencèrent à lui jeter des pierres et des cailloux -
ce n'était pas à Chautauqua. C'était dans une autre ville -
parce que les gens voyaient un homme squelettique, un sage atteint de folie,
une sorte de hippie, avec une jambe pleine de sang et un chien pourri sur l'épaule,
hurlant que le futur Bouddha était arrivé.
Naturellement, ils le chassèrent de la ville.
Mais à la sortie du village, une vieille femme, gardienne du repos des âmes,
vit sur son épaule un pied orné de bijoux posé sur un lotus orné de bijoux,
elle vit le chien mais elle reconnut le pied du Maitreya, et elle offrit une fleur.
Cela lui donna du courage, et partit en compagnie du Maitreya.
Maitreya l'emmena alors dans un paradis,
de la même façon dont les buddhistes révèlent les mythes.
Maitreya le garda alors au paradis pendant cinq ans,
lui dictant cinq volumes compliqués
sur la façon de cultiver la compassion.
En fait, je voudrais vous expliquer l'une de ces méthodes.
Elle est très connue, c'est " La Méthode des Septuples Causes pour Développer la Compassion
On commence par méditer et visualiser les êtres vivants comme un tout,
et tout - même les animaux - est sous forme humaine.
Les animaux sont sous une de leurs incarnations humaines. Les humains sont des humains.
Parmi eux, on pense à ses amis et à ceux qu'on aime, le cercle autour de la table.
Ensuite on pense à ses ennemis, et on pense aux gens neutres.
Ensuite on essaye de dire "Ceux que j'aime, je les aime.
Mais après tout, ils sont gentils avec moi.
Quelquefois, on s'est disputés. Parfois ils n'ont pas été amicaux.
Ils m'énervaient. Les frères se disputent. Parents et enfants se disputent.
D'une certaine façon, si je les aime autant c'est parce qu'ils sont gentils avec moi.
Pour les gens neutres, je ne sais pas. Ils pourraient être tout aussi agréables.
Et mes ennemis, je ne les aime pas parce qu'ils sont méchants avec moi.
Mais ils sont gentils avec quelqu'un d'autre. Cela pourrait être moi."
Et parce qu'on a tous eu un nombre infini de vies antérieures,
les bouddhistes pensent qu'on a tous un jour été parents les uns des autres,
et dans la vision bouddhiste, tout le monde, chacun d'entre vous ici,
bien que personne ne s'en souvienne, et moi non plus, a, dans une vie antérieure,
a été ma mère, et je vous présente mes excuses pour les problèmes que je vous ai crées.
Et j'ai également été votre mère, d'ailleurs.
J'ai été femme, et j'ai été, à chacun d'entre vous, votre mère dans une vie antérieure,
c'est ce que pensent les bouddhistes.
Dans cette vie, ma mère est vraiment super. Mais chacun d'entre vous, d'une certaine façon,
fait partie de la mère éternelle.
Vous m'avez suggéré cette expression, "la maman éternelle". C'est merveilleux.
C'est comme ça que font les bouddhistes.
Un croyant, chrétien, pourra penser que tous les humains, même ses ennemis, sont les enfants de Dieu.
Dans ce sens-là, nous sommes liés.
Ils ont d'abord crée cet élément fondamental de l'égalité.
On a donc tendance à ramener ça uniquement à ceux que l'on aime -
dans la méditation - et on s'ouvre à ceux qu'on ne connaît pas.
On calme vraiment son hostilité, ce "je-ne-veux-pas-éprouver-de-compassion-pour-eux"
ceux qui sont pour nous les méchants, ceux qu'on hait, qu'on n'aime pas.
Ainsi, on ne ressent plus de haine envers quiconque. On rend chacun égal à l'autre. C'est très important.
L'étape qui suit est ce qu'on appelle la reconnaissance de la mère.
Il s'agit de reconnaître chaque être en tant que membre de sa famille.
On élargit son esprit. On prend ce sentiment lorsque l'on pense à une maman,
et on l'étend à tous les êtres, dans cette méditation.
On voit alors la mère dans chaque être.
On voit cette expression présente sur le visage d'une mère,
ce regard vers cet enfant,
ce miracle qu'elle a créé dans son propre corps, en tant que mammifère,
[cette expression] dans laquelle elle exprime une vraie compassion, où elle EST l'autre, et s'identifie totalement.
Souvent, la vie de cet autre est plus importante que sa propre vie.
C'est pourquoi ceci est la forme la plus puissante d'altruisme.
La mère, c'est le modèle de l'altruisme envers les être humains,
dans les traditions spirituelles.
Ainsi, on réfléchit jusqu'à ce qu'on puisse voir cette expression maternelle en tous les êtres.
Les gens se moquent de moi parce que je disais
que je méditais sur la "maman en Dick Cheney", je la voyais comme ma mère,
quand j'étais contrarié par tout le mal qu'il a fait en Irak.
Je méditais sur George Bush. Sous sa forme féminine, il fait une maman plutôt mignonne.
Il a des petites oreilles et il sourit et vous berce dans ses bras.
Et on l'imagine en train de vous nourrir.
Par contre, la grosse moustache de Saddam Hussein est un problème.
Mais il faut s'imaginer qu'il est une mère.
C'est comme ça qu'on fait. On prend chaque être humain qui nous paraît bizarre,
et on imagine la façon dont il pourrait nous être familier.
On fait ça jusqu'à ce qu'on ressente vraiment
que tous les êtres nous sont familiers.
Personne ne vous est étranger. Il n'y a plus d' "autre".
Vous diminuez le sentiment d'altérité entre les êtres vivants.
De là, on se rappelle la gentillesse des mères en général,
si on peut se rappeler la gentillesse de sa propre mère,
la gentillesse de son conjoint,
ou, si on est soi-même une mère, son propre comportement avec ses enfants.
On devient très sentimental, on cultive intensément ses sentiments.
Des larmes couleront peut-être, pleines de gratitude et de gentillesse.
Et on relie cela à son sentiment que tout le monde possède ce potentiel maternel.
Chaque être, même ceux qui ont l'air le plus méchant, peut être maternel.
Troisièmement, on passe à ce qui s'appelle un sentiment de gratitude.
On veut retourner cette gentillesse qu'on a reçu des autres.
La quatrième étape, c'est d'arriver à ce qui s'appelle l'amour affectueux.
Chaque étape peut prendre des semaines, des mois, ou des jours
ça dépend de votre pratique, vous pouvez même réaliser cette méditation en une seule fois.
Ensuite, on pense à quel point les gens sont gentils lorsqu'ils sont heureux,
lorsqu'ils sont satisfaits.
Chaque être est beau lorsqu'il ressent intérieurement la joie.
Leur visage n'est pas comme ça. Chacun, lorsqu'il est en colère, est laid.
mais lorsqu'il est heureux, il est beau.
Et l'on voit alors les gens dans leur bonheur potentiel.
On ressent de l'amour pour eux, on veut qu'ils soient heureux, même les ennemis.
En fait, c'est très logique.
on trouve que Jésus n'est pas réaliste lorsqu'il dit d'aimer ses ennemis.
C'est ce qu'il dit, et on trouve qu'il n'est pas réaliste
et un peu prétentieux... "Bien content pour lui, moi je peux pas le faire"
En fait, c'est une question de pratique.
Si on aime son ennemi, on veut que son ennemi soit heureux.
Si votre ennemi était vraiment heureux, pourquoi s'embêterait-il à être votre ennemi ?
C'est pénible d'être là à vous courir après.
Ils pourraient être quelque part à se détendre, prendre du bon temps.
C'est donc logique de vouloir que son ennemi soit heureux
parce qu'alors il arrêtera d'être votre ennemi, car c'est trop de problèmes.
En tout cas, c'est ça, l'amour affectueux.
Ensuite, la cinquième étape est la compassion, la compassion universelle.
et c'est là que l'on regarde en face la réalité de tous les êtres auxquels vous pouvez penser.
On les regarde, et on les voit tels qu'ils sont.
Et on se rend compte combien ils sont malheureux, la plupart du temps.
On voit ce front ridé que les gens ont.
Et on réalise qu'ils n'éprouvent même pas de compassion pour eux-mêmes.
Leur vie est dictée par le devoir et les obligations.
"Il faut que j'aie ceci. J'ai besoin de plus. Je ne vaux rien. Je dois faire quelque chose."
Et ils courent dans tous les sens, paniqués.
Ils voient ça comme un truc macho, une dure discipline qu'ils s'imposent.
Mais ils sont en fait cruels envers eux-mêmes.
Et bien sûr, ils sont cruels et impitoyables envers les autres.
Du coup, ils n'ont jamais de réaction positive.
Plus ils réussissent, plus ils ont de pouvoir,
moins ils sont heureux.
C'est là que l'on ressent de la compassion pour eux.
Et on sent qu'il faut faire quelque chose.
C'est la motivation.
On espère que le choix de l'action, bien sûr, sera facile à réaliser
que pour ce pauvre Asanga qui s'occupait des vers sur le chien,
mais parce qu'il avait cette motivation, peu importait qui il avait en face de lui,
il voulait aider.
Mais bien sûr, cela n'est pas réalisable. Il aurait dû fonder une SPA dans la ville
et obtenir de l'aide scientifique pour les chiens et les vers.
Et je suis sûr qu'il l'a fait plus tard. Mais cela montre simplement l'état d'esprit.
L'étape suivante - la sixième étape après la compassion universelle -
est cette chose qui nous lie réellement aux besoins des autres,
et on a aussi de la compassion pour soi-même,
ce n'est pas que sentimental. On a peut-être peur.
Une personne mauvaise se rend de plus en plus malheureuse
en étant de plus en plus méchant avec les autres
et se faisant punir plus tard de différentes façons.
Dans le bouddhisme, cela les rattrape dans une future incarnation.
Dans la religion théiste, ils sont punis par Dieu.
Dans le matérialisme, ils pensent qu'ils s'en sortent
en mourant, mais ce n'est pas le cas.
Alors ils se réincarnent en je ne sais quoi.
Bref. Je ne vais pas m'étaler là-dessus.
L'étape suivante est ce qu'on appelle la responsabilité universelle.
Et ça, c'est très important -- la Charte de la Compassion
doit nous ammener à nous épanouir grâce à la véritable compassion,
ce qu'on appelle la responsabilité universelle.
Et c'est cela que signifie l'enseignement suprême de Sa Sainteté le Dalai Lama,
c'est cela qu'il enseigne partout dans le monde,
c'est la religion commune de l'humanité : la gentillesse.
Mais gentillesse rime avec responsabilité universelle.
Tout ce qui arrive aux autres nous arrive à nous-même,
que l'on devrait en prendre la responsabilité
et faire tout ce que l'on peut,
même si c'est au plus bas niveau.
Il faut absolument le faire. C'est inconcevable de ne pas le faire.
Et pour finir, cela amène un nouveau sens à la vie
dans laquelle on vit aussi bien pour soi que pour les autres,
et on se rend compte de son propre bonheur --
Et on est joyeux et heureux .
On ne doit pas croire que la compassion vous rend malheureux.
La compassion vous rend heureux.
La première personne à être heureuse, lorsqu'on éprouve une grande compassion, est soi-même,
même si on n'a encore rien fait pour aider les autres.
Le changement qui se fait dans l'esprit est déjà quelque chose pour les autres.
Ils peuvent sentir en vous cette qualité nouvelle,
et cela déjà les aide et leur montre l'exemple.
Mais voilà que cette horloge dénuée de compassion me montre que c'est terminé.
Alors, cultivez la compassion, lisez la charte, répandez-la
et développez-la en vous-même.
Ne vous limitez pas à penser "je suis compatissant, je ne suis pas compatissant"
et à vous dire que vous êtes coincé.
Vous pouvez développer cela. Vous pouvez réduire ce manque de compassion,
la cruauté, l'endurcissement, la négligence envers les autres.
Soyez universellement responsable d'eux,
et non seulement Dieu et la maman éternelle souriront,
mais Karen Armstrong sourira.
Merci beaucoup.